at a museum in Tokyo
researchers have set up a workshop where
they're looking to prove that robots can
be imbued with life hello are huge eat
your red pill and try to keep up
professor Takashi Ikegami has helped
create this thing which looks like it
comes straight from ex machina central
casting through a series of sensors and
artificial intelligence software this
Android looks out into the world and
reacts to what it sees the Android is an
effective olve it based on what it's AI
software seems to like basically there
are two different mechanisms one is
autonomous or rhythm generators okay
it's coupled with each other also there
is artificial neural networks
spontaneously firing and sending signals
to each other someone approaches the
Android the sensors detect the movement
and then the software kicks in to
determine how the robot will move in
response
but for the moment it has a movement
style that could be described as that
really drunk guy at the party okay so in
each one of these sensor boxes right
here yes there's two cameras yep and
this is measuring the distance so when I
come closer or further away from the
machine then both wood has to do
something it has to do react to them
yeah you guys will add more and more
sensors yeah we can put like a
temperature sensors sound sensors many
other senses armed with more sensors the
robot can make more judgments about its
environment and more nuanced reactions
over time the movements and gurgles
change
the thinking is that the robot will
eventually form its own personality and
possibly even language what's the deal
with the noise is it hungry this sound
is designed by my student a behavior is
modifying those sounds the sound is
changing all the time it's more like in
a primitive language that's I think the
interesting part of it right our babies
we don't have to tell everything to the
baby but baby can learn unconsciously by
interacting with people to start with
the environment right once we have a
bunch of life-track systems around us
maybe our concept of what is life will
be very much different and then if we
want to coexist with robots
then we'll maybe have to learn different
languages then different way of thinking
so that doesn't freak you out you think
that's justice I think it's much more
ideal to me coping with this you know
very violent world right now
well thank you for letting me see your
Android thank you thank you
oh she said something I think he said he
likes you
you